tie is like kissing your twin brother
that's what they say no absolutely not
hey I'm Hannah I'm fresh off the last
battle with the Sklar brothers Randy and
Jason how are we feeling feel great oh
my god I mean I was so nervous before
cuz it's not what we do we celebrity
judge the roast battle and that is a
loose interpretation of the word
celebrity did you have anything going
into it off-limits there were a couple
things yeah we're humans he cleared like
intense stuff with me and we know that
we're just jobs jobs Jason had a
hemorrhoid surgery that didn't work okay
so win or lose tonight his ass is
getting creamed
yeah the hemorrhoid joke really got me
yeah damn right
oh my god I'll tell you about a good
doctor dr. Fletcher the questioners name
is pleasure and he's like I've won more
to looking at Randy is like looking at a
mirror a mirror that keeps me from my
potential I don't know if you could tell
this was in the last year Jason's gained
about ten pounds I could tell because
I've been carrying him professionally
for the last decade I could do this for
hours we have 45 years of pent-up anger
oh we could keep the husband wife till
death do you part
Joe you made this the bride that's right
Sara told wash and Joe less do I say
married couple like how do you guys like
to be safe buddies yeah you lost yeah
geez you know this ain't like that I
came in second is what happened you
either of you have a joke you wish you'd
said that you didn't get out Joseph
Bernie bro
or he's a socialist so he wants to share
his herpes with everyone sarah has had a
lot of sex because she's a babe well
she's a pig in the city actually has
been really nice he's opened a lot of
doors for me he's got me a lot of spots
at clubs and on my
just kidding I don't have herpes that's
gross I mean I learned a lot about you
and yeah yeah yeah luckily it stays
forever
we need to hug it out you want to give a
kiss to each other I love to kiss yeah
yeah maybe yeah yeah yeah beautiful yeah
that was slower than I was expecting he
went real slow on that one
Sarah really eased her way into that
[Applause]